let's go to rob from Massachusetts Rob
welcome to the show
hi thank you all first time on I have a
really quick question sure I have a
right-wing friend at work and he tends
to
like comment on on YouTube things I post
and the thing is I've learned to think
like he does so there's like a little
version of him in my head
um like trying to be a great person and
I wonder if that happens to you if you
find it useful for arguments or if it's
just like frustrating because you know
that I think like bigger themselves no
that's real it's really good and it's
useful and and I would argue that it's
actually quite healthy which is okay we
see a headline uh gas prices down two
months in a row I think it's great to
say okay
how are how are Republicans going to
react to this do they have a point if so
should I modify my view if not why is it
that they're actually wrong I mean maybe
gas prices is a bad example but I think
that that's actually very healthy it's
it's arguably a version of Steel Manning
which is rather than straw Manning your
political opponents you Steel Man and
say what's the best case I can make for
their View and if I still think it's a
bad case it reinforces that I've come to
the right conclusion I think that's very
healthy as long as it doesn't become
like intrusive or pathological
oh great yeah I listen to Sam here some
people with steel Manning so that's I
never thought about that okay thank you
all right Rob thank you very much that
that last bit was a little garbled I
didn't understand that but I did
understand thank you and I really do
appreciate that